uh we can look at
vaccines you know we're about to we're
about to have one of the most aggressive
vaccination programs the world has ever
seen
but we are unfortunately doing it right
at the peak of viral transmission when
millions and millions of people are
still getting infected
and when we do that that just gives this
virus so many more opportunities i mean
orders of magnitude
more opportunity to mutate around our
immune system
now if we were to vaccinate everyone
when there's not a lot of virus
then there's just not a lot of virus and
so there's not going to be as many
you know i don't even know how many
zeros are at the end of however many
viral particles there are in the world
right now
you know more than quadrillions you know
and so if you assume that at any given
time somebody might have trillions of
virus in them and
any given individual so then you know
multiply trillions by millions and yeah
you know you get a lot of viruses out
there and
and if you start applying pressure
ecological pressure to
this virus that that you know when it's
that abundant
opportunity for a virus to sneak around
immunity especially when all the
vaccines are identical
essentially um it takes one to mutate
and it jumps oh takes one takes one in
the whole world you know and we have to
we have to not forget that this
particular virus was
one it was one opportunity and it has
spread across the globe and there's no
reason that can't happen tomorrow
i knew you know it's scary
you